the concert event of the year
congratulations you're leading the pack
at the acm awards with seven nominations
no big deal
it's a big deal for me i'm not gonna lie
definitely a surprise but a very welcome
one never been the most nominated at any
award show
in my life
congratulations on all your success from
famous friends i mean working with kane
brown what was that whole experience
like for you
i'd written it on the bus and i just had
a demo from the bus
and i said it to him and i'm like hey
man put your ear on this i think this
would be cool like as a duet i just want
to ask you first before i ask anybody
else and he was like dude i'm in
obviously this song is just bringing me
a lot of firsts and it's cool because i
got to do it with somebody i was already
friends with speaking of famous friends
do you have any famous friends that we
don't know about i'm a cowboys fan
football fan i've obviously
gotten to know a lot of people over the
years but i've gotten to know dak
prescott pretty well you know that's
your your favorite sports team getting
to know
you know the quarterback or the league
guy it's pretty awesome when you have
this bucket list of people who you would
love to collaborate with who's number
one for you tim mcgraw
so eventually me and tim are going to do
something i'm going to hound him it is
he made a mistake he gave me his phone
number and so now it's you're not
getting out of this time